hey man how are you good to see you
again nice to see you um i want to start
with uh
actually thank you i've really enjoyed
your work the past few years oh thank
you very much i just want to thank you
for what you've been doing it's really
been entertaining to watch thank you
very very much that means a lot thank
you
um so i am i like throwing some
curveballs at the beginning um if
someone has actually
never seen anything that you've done
what's the first thing you want them to
watch
oh that is a
curveball
i i don't know i don't know that uh
who i don't i don't know i'm my i'm
proud of different things for different
reasons you know i i
loved being on girls i loved patterson
you know i i
i
i don't know why that you know that's a
i don't know that's a hard question to
to answer
it also kind of implies that they would
enjoy it so i i i or maybe it doesn't
but um
uh what
which would be a big assumption
um i i don't know i'll think about it
maybe at the end though
sure um you you have hosted snl three
times and all three episodes have been
fantastic
thank you i'm wondering uh what do i
need to do to get you to do more snl uh
because the episodes have just been so
good
i i mean
you know if it ever works out i i love
doing it and it's really fun and those
right the writers there are really
incredible
and lauren is great so i you know
whenever they uh
if the stars align it um
uh i i'm always down to to do it i i now
i have an answer to the first one uh
patterson i will say patterson b uh just
because i love that movie i love jim
jarmish as a filmmaker and i and i like
what the movie is about and in a kind of
is kind of an anti-conflict movie and
and and it is about really uh
um
the how boring sometimes the process of
making something can be and how
uninteresting that uh where inspiration
can kind of come from and i i'm always
fascinated by movies myself that have a
very strong theme about process because
i hate it so much i i don't i'm so
impatient that as soon as we start i
want it to be over with and
i want the end result but just because
of
of everything has to have a process that
i'm always grateful that i went through
it so i i that might be a um
a fuzzy answer but patterson would be
the thing that i i really i really loved
and i loved other things for different
reasons but i i really loved jim and and
fred elms who shot it and the people
that i made that with
i just realized now why you love working
with ridley scott because he is so fast
when he is filming with the multiple
cameras and uh very few takes can you is
that one of the reasons why you loved
working with him on back-to-back
projects i do because it's a challenge
from me my habit is to want to do it
again and to try to um chase perfection
which which i know is you know
intellectually is a stupid idea to like
try to make it more perfect but he
he gives you a lot of faith
and and set it up that it is very
similar to theater because there's so
many uh
um cameras there's not one frame that
you're trying to make a picture in
there's uh cameras that sometimes you
don't find until you're in the middle of
the scene and you look up and there's a
whole camera crew you know kind of
hiding in the corner
so it does become like you're you're
you're less conscious of them in a way
it's which seems counterintuitive you'd
think the more cameras you'd the more
conscious you are but he gives you
incredible freedom and faith
and he's incredibly prepared he has uh
he's been doing it so long that he
doesn't sweat small stuff if actors come
in and want to change his plan he just
rolls with it and and still
is uh humble and hilarious
i mean i could go on there's there's a
million reasons other than that his
process is so different than mine that i
i find it really refreshing and after
you work with him you do kind of go on
to other sets and we're like we're
wasting so much time and
and money you know i just realized uh
you're probably going to lose your mind
when you eventually work with fincher
and he says to you hey we're going to do
50 takes of this scene you're like why
don't we do 60.
no no i mean there's some there's value
in that too i just finished uh another
movie with noah bomback and noah likes
to do a lot of takes you know he he
likes to chase you know
you know a perfect take and and will do
it a lot and and there's value in that
too you know there's no similar to
acting you know there's a lot of great
actors in this i i don't think one of us
worked the same way you know it was all
very different you know
uh
and
there's information and not one way is
better or worse it's just uh that's one
of the the luxuries of getting to work
with different people who are very
singular in how they like to work
yeah it i've spoken to so many actors
and filmmakers and it's amazing the
differences in approach to the craft and
how it all gets to the same place yeah
yeah which is also infuriating sometimes
you know that's what makes it i think
interesting to keep exploring because
sometimes you feel like you're feeling
it and no one is feeling anything
because it's not for you you know
eventually it's it's for an audience
you're just kind of uh you're a conduit
and then sometimes you uh are feeling it
and it actually is coming across
and sometimes the opposite is true so
you know some
you feel less prepared it comes you know
there's no rhyme or reason you know you
can do the the things you can and be
available know your lines and things
like that but it always comes down to
this like weird mystery that no one can
really articulate you know 100
uh i am curious what it was like for you
seeing jared the first time
in the makeup and the way he was going
to look in the film and did he actually
try to play a trick on you like stand
next to you and you're like who who is
this guy
no he did that with al uh he al he uh he
was next to uh
alan talking to him and like i think uh
al got really scared and was gonna come
well not scared but he was gonna call
security because he's like how did this
guy just get in here
um and it was actually jared jared i i
saw from a distance and obviously like
like everyone who saw the the first
images or poster i didn't recognize them
and that's how i met him i i didn't
really see him as himself until uh
until we've been doing this this all
this uh that press stuff
uh obviously you share the screen uh
with lady gaga uh a lot and you guys
have some fantastic scenes um what was
it actually like seeing her because her
accent is so good and she gives her
everything to the role what was it like
actually working with her and watching
her commitment to this performance
it's it's it's working with a uh an
actor you know
um
a great actor who's prepared and
and is willing to kind of uh
um
take advantage of the time and
make sure that there's no stone unturned
so in that sense it's easy
uh because uh uh she because really
great actors make it easy for you
they're
they've done their work they're prepared
and they have to be willing to throw it
all away
you know in service of you know this is
all
uh
been said by a million times but it's
true you throw it all away when you're
when you're actually doing the scene and
she has all of that she has
an obviously presence
and uh
a total awareness of where she is in her
body
so it's kind of like
easy is my simple answer because she
is an easy person to act across
uh from because she's giving you so much
so in in that sense it was it was great
it was great and i had a great time when
we were shooting it
and i feel like you can feel it in the
movie where
you know we're where you start seeing
um you know
we shout mostly in order but not so much
uh but you see our relationship grow and
that's it's so much what's not on the
page it's uh
her being us both being willing her
being willing to
you know put it all aside and uh and you
know play the scenes which so it was
great i loved it
i have to stop there thank you so much
for your time and again
uh thank you for your work thanks a lot
thank you